over 1 million people in France are
striking over a government plan to raise
the retirement age from 62 to 64. we'll
follow what ultimately happens in France
but this raises an interesting question
about the United States Republicans are
already talking about what about raising
the retirement age in the context of
Social Security and even though
Republicans have insisted many times in
different ways that they're not going to
mess with Social Security raising the
retirement age would be a major major
change will we see a million people in
the U.S protest that change if indeed
Republicans get the opportunity to make
it happen I don't know